guys welcome to the just apparently
thanks YouTube channel today I'm doing a
Car Talk
um I'm Loki sitting on the side of the
road because my friend is I'm picking
her up from the airport so I'm just
waiting but I have a lot of thoughts so
the first off
I want to tell you guys about my life
the last like
a couple of weeks so first of all thank
you for a million subscribers
now I made a whole video for a million
Subs but it's still being edited so this
might come out before that comes out but
whatever whatever but
thank you guys so much um it's been
crazy
I wanted to hit a million before January
1st but I hit the fourth so I was like
you know what close enough right
I knew that tape video would take me to
a million but let me tell you something
about hitting the million let me tell
you something about hitting a million
a lot of creators have now come forward
saying women ruin the manosphere blah
blah blah blah blah
and it's just like I was thinking about
this a lot of you guys complaining we're
the ones that helped me
so at 20 000 subscribers I was being
helped with my set
I was being accepted collabs all this
stuff and now I'm like
now
what Jay
look it you can't please everybody
that's what I've learned in life
the bigger I get the more you have a
Target on your back and the more people
are just excited to get one on you in
interviews the more which is fine Fair
sport the more likely people will just
criticize you blah blah blah freedom of
speech baby freedom of speech so this
gets me into the question I've been
doing interviews all across the country
and this has been nuts
I got to go home for a week spend time
with my family and it's hard because
everything's getting you know I get
opportunities now that I'm home and I'm
like I try to make the most of them but
at the same time okay
getting off topic so
on these interviews I keep getting the
same question why do you do this and I
haven't really had a good answer because
when I started the channel
and I hate this sometimes I I'm not even
gonna filter myself at all because what
I'll do is I'll think of this person
will tear this apart or try to take me
out of context if I say this but okay
I'm just gonna say it so
I didn't start this channel
with an end goal in mind to be honest
like I love
I've always been so curious about what
is the truth about the world so
when I first started reacting to Red
Pill content it was so interesting
because there's an airplane there's an
airplane wait wait it was so interesting
because I had never really heard the
man's point of view and as a girl like
this [ __ ] is shocking when they're like
we don't like [ __ ] and I'm like I've
always innately knew you know don't
sleep around my mom I had a good mother
but I've just never heard people talk
like that so at first when I'm hearing
alpha male strategies you know [ __ ]
these hoes the street street sleep also
AMS you're funny you're a cool content
creator I I'm sorry I used to use an
example
but I watched a lot of your [ __ ] back in
the day and
it was so interesting so then I was
thinking okay
and I've always been more conservative
I'll say that I've always always been
more conservative I've always been
opinionated and so then I was like why
don't we have
uh a panel and
do questions about relationships and
like some conservative topics you know
so that was so much fun so then when I
was on the show I was thinking oh you
know what
I bet some of the girls would understand
these topics better if I just sat down
with them and showed them this video
where someone's smarter than me explain
this stuff
and then they would and it was so cool
you could see their their minds change
on camera and that was like one of the
beautiful things that blew up this
channel
so then it's like it gets bigger the
show gets bigger everything gets bigger
and now people are looking at me to be
some sort of authority in the red pill
space manosphere space I create Men's
Central contract you know and I'd like
to also add while I'm doing this I I
start to notice all the ways society is
discriminating against men not only I've
never been that like
into the pay Gap or that [ __ ] like
and if I was it was young you know what
I mean like I don't think so but who
knows anyways
so but to think about that men are
openly discriminated against not just oh
50 50 oh it's even so then it's like I
just start to think of like how unfair
some of the laws are from what I
understand and I could be wrong okay and
so then I just start talking about this
stuff
and me if I didn't set out
to be the
you know the person
that is pretending to be the most
knowledgeable I didn't come out
pretending to have the most advice life
experience I didn't come out wanting to
tell people what to do at all
I just wanted to
make entertaining content and discover
more of the truth about the world and
that's what was so interesting to me was
you could just
things that I never noticed in society
I just started to notice and people say
you could brainwashed blah blah blah and
so
then I what I was thinking is I could
start to create cultural moments where
okay I've heard what the men are saying
I've heard what the women are saying
let's bring two ends of the opposite
Spectrum together
and make a video make content and it's
so important because we have so much
media out there that's so tailored to
women this is the one that's for men and
more and it doesn't even need to be for
men men just find it more palatable it's
it's honest it's more real and that's
why I brought together Andrew Tate and
Brittany Renner because Brittany Renner
while it's one person and one story
there are a million stories just like
her on a smaller scale maybe she didn't
marry her you know an NBA player not
everyone can do that or get the kid off
of one whatever but maybe she did it
with the town basketball team or you
know whatever it is
and that's that's why and I got a lot of
flack for interviewing Brittany you're
letting her do a whole apology tour blah
blah blah and I'm just like guys you
don't have to watch my channel like it's
totally fine if you don't think I'm I
know enough or whatever and that's
that's the thing about getting bigger
you get like almost like a Target on
your back where people are just so
and I'm like guys my goal was to hit
100k this year I just enjoy making
content this is the crazy thing
then you get accusations of sorry I just
have a lot to get off my chest you get
accusations of buying subscribers I
haven't bought [ __ ] and the crazy thing
is the people that accuse me of that and
they spent 10 minutes asking me how I
did it I could explain them step-by-step
process of how to blow up on YouTube
and then I get oh well your Channel's
run by a man and I'm like okay okay
let's chill out if there's one man that
influences my channel more than anyone
it's my dad
two
I get to pick the man like he doesn't
run at all like today okay
sneako interview we're afraid is gonna
get us a strike and it still might
my manager didn't want to post it he's
like the risk outweigh the rewards me I
I'm I'm here to make entertaining
content that tells the truth about the
world
and you know discover more truth about
the world in my process
so I made the final decision I normally
will allow him but at the end of the day
I hired him I picked him who's running
it when I just through certain decisions
I don't like making but if there's
something that's really important to me
or I really want I I don't have to
are you guys crazy like oh my God sorry
I'm just going off it's just like
everyone wants to criticize like you're
you're a grifter your fraud you're this
you're that the women are ruining this
and I'm like guys I thought I was for
freedom of speech
we're just talking here
I'm sorry I I was good at YouTube I'm
sorry I was successful fast but I didn't
come here saying I'm the end-all beetle
I came here to I love I love okay
this person why I do what I do I love
having deep conversations with people
and
I I kind of have ADD so I have a hard
time staying on topic sometimes but I
love I've just always loved having
conversations about Society does that
mean I know everything about Society no
does that mean I'm
smartest in the room I know everything
okay call me an idiot call me dumb
whatever
but
I love facilitating conversations I love
creating entertaining content and I love
if I learned something that's true
why would I not repeat it
oh my God
oh my God so if I if I hear someone say
that the wage Gap isn't true and I
Google it and it's not true but on a
podcast I can't recite exactly like
where I heard that from does that make
it any less true oh my God you people
sorry people drive me nuts I love you
guys I love you
but there's just been a lot of things
I've been wanting to address but I don't
want to because I don't want drama and I
don't want to have beef and I don't want
to fight and I'm the woman and I'm the
woman
I said I post this oh I don't know if I
should post because then you just give
people fuel but
that's why I do what I do that's why I
do what I do
it's not to tell people what to do and
that's why I said on the show with Hafiz
I said entertainment because I think
look at look how much the left has
influenced Society through entertainment
look how much they've done it [ __ ]
conservatives why don't we take notes
because it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter how knowledgeable how you are how
smart you are if you're not entertaining
and you're not likable if you're not
either of those two things No One's
Gonna watch it
so
look I'm just saying take notes from
freaking China taking over Tick Tock you
know anyways
um I never even called myself a
manosphere red pill contact I think I
put I react to red but I don't know I
just Give opinions I talk about things
that are interesting
um
and when I found out all the stuff about
how men are discriminated against like
90 percent
of the time women get custody and why
and guys I was brainwashed too why did I
never question that
I mean on some level I knew but
or when women ruin homes for cheating I
never questioned that
I was like leave his ass but then it's
like how selfish is that when you think
about it
so
as a woman I'm I'm thankful for red pill
because
it changed my world viewing a lot of
stuff
um flash manosphere medicine center
content I at least got to learn like how
men think
and then they'll be like nah oh no blah
blah blah okay
yeah so that's
I feel like I just slide a lot off my
chest because sometimes it just piles up
and everyone's just
Pearl do this Pearl dude that way pros
this Pros that and it shouldn't bother
me because I get so much love too like I
get so much love and I don't want to
feel ungrateful because
like honestly I get messages every day
talking about how
how you know great the channel is and
how much they love what I'm doing and
but sometimes especially when people
help too early on and then you pass them
and then their tune changes it just it
kind of bothers me um I don't know I'm
human I guess
um
but
yeah I'm all for freedom of speech
um
I get nervous doing these coffee
thoughts because
I don't know I just get nervous but this
is just me being honest transparent I
get nervous
um all right like the video on your way
out I have other thoughts that I'm gonna
do coffee thoughts on but this is my
coffee thought for now like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time